- That moment when the officer's kneeling
on him, and he's saying, “I can't breathe.”
And you see the look
in the officer's eyes.
And the thing I kept going back
to is, like, this motherfucker
thinks he's gonna get away with it.
He thinks there's no repercussions for this.
- I'm Taylor Rooks,
and these are conversations about
defining one's relationship to Blackness
and how that defines their America.
So, JJ, all of these
begin with the same question.
So my question for you is when
did you realize that being white
was different from being Black?
- It's a, it's an interesting
question, for sure.
So I have to provide a
little bit of background.
I'm in the middle of five kids.
We, growing up, we
lived out in the sticks.
My parents were like hippies.
I mean, they lived sort of
an alternative lifestyle.
We were in Cookeville,
Tennessee, for a while.
They had, like, a farm that we
lived on, 11 acres outside
Charlottesville, Virginia.
Then we moved to Roanoke, where I
grew up, and I was home-schooled.
And so in fifth grade, I
started going to public school.
And that same year, I also started
playing AAU basketball with
the city team, the Roanoke Jaguars.
And we had, like, probably 75 percent Black
players and 25 percent white players.
It was, it was a nice sort of mix of guys.
From that time on, I knew it was different
because I would have conversations with my
friends on the team that were Black.
And I would have conversations
with my friends on the team
that were white, and it was immediately
apparent to me that Black people
are treated differently in this country.
The guys would talk about their aunts
or their parents or their living
situations, or what it was like at school,
what it was like to go to the mall.
And, you know, I'm having these
conversations all throughout elementary
school now, junior high school.
And then, you know, I went to
Boo Williams when I was 14.
I played with the 17-year-old group for three years.
He's like an AAU legend.
So I would drive four-and-a-half
hours across the state and do
practices and tournaments with them.
And I think that was, those three years
was really what, like, solidified sort
of, you know, my, my belief system
on race in America because I had,
you know, we traveled all
over the world with this team,
and I just had these amazing and
candid and open conversations with
guys about race and what it's like.
- So when you said you guys would have
conversations, like, with your white
teammates versus your Black teammates,
what was it that’d stick out? Like, when
the Black teammates would talk
about going to the mall, how was that
experience different from when the
white teammates would talk about going to the mall?
- Well, it wasn't even
just the conversations.
I experienced it with them.
You know, I can, I can go—
I went to a county public school.
I can
go to the mall as a 13-year-old
or a 14-year-old adolescent
with two or three white friends.
And then I can go to the same mall
with my AAU teammates, and how we're
treated in a store is differently,
how we're looked at is differently.
When we would stop at restaurants
on the road at AAU tournaments, it’s like
how we're looked at. You can, you
can sense it, you can feel it.
So I, again, I think that
the, the thing that I've, like,
continued throughout my adult life—
um,
and again, I've been very fortunate;
basketball has given me a lot of
opportunity and has expanded my
worldview in a lot of different
ways, but especially on race.
And I've been able to have
these conversations now for,
I mean, jeez, almost 26 years.
These are conversations that I've
had. And these are conversations that
I've been able to have in a room with
a couple white
teammates and a couple Black
teammates all at the same time.
So we've, we've been having
conversations about this
for, for a long time.
- So in a time like now—because I've,
I've been very interested in how Black
people experience this versus how white
people experience this—when you're
on your phone and you're scrolling
on Twitter, and you see a video—
- Mhmm.
- Of a Black man being murdered by the police.
- Yeah.
- Walk me through your reaction
from the moment you see the video
to the moment you kind of calm down from seeing the video.
- I'm gonna
make this personal. So I'm not gonna
make a broad generalization about
what white people see versus what Black
people see, but I'll make it what I see.
So I have what's called empathy,
and I have what's called compassion.
So I can't watch that video
through the lens of a Black person
because I'm not a Black person.
But I can try at least, or, or,
you know, you know, try to
comprehend what that would be like.
It's horrific. It's emotional. It's raw.
It's visceral.
It makes you sick to your stomach
when you see what
happened to George Floyd.
You know, again, that first week
especially, when the emotions were so
raw, you know, I cried multiple times.
And it seemed like every time you
went on Twitter, every time you’d turn
on the news, you know, it's, it's that
moment when the officer's kneeling on
him, and he's saying, “I can't breathe.”
And you see the look
in the officer's eyes.
And the thing I kept going back to
is, like, this motherfucker thinks
he's gonna get away with it.
He thinks there's no
repercussions for this.
Um,
and look, if we're talking about,
specifically about police
brutality, I think there is a culture
where there isn't accountability.
I think that's been shown time
and time and time again, where
officers have mistreated
and sometimes murdered Black Americans,
and there hasn't been any consequences.
There has not been any consequences.
And that's the look on his face.
I know there's not a consequence to this.
There's a smirk to it.
There's this, there's this notion
of I'm more powerful than you.
And that, that makes you sick.
It makes you sick.
That's not how it should be.
That's not the world I wanna be in.
That's not the society that I
wanna raise my children in.
So, yeah, it's, it's emotional.
It's emotional for anybody.
And, and, you know, obviously I've
talked to a lot of people over the last
few weeks, and I've talked to a lot of
people from a lot of different races.
It's emotional for everyone.
Um,
and again, I just go back to, like,
trying to view it through the lens
of a Black American and what that
must be like, and it's difficult to
comprehend, but it just makes you sick.
- I wanna talk about those
emotions cuz everything you said,
I absolutely agree with.
So for me as I go through this—
- Yeah.
- The emotions that I feel are hurt,
disposable, insignificant.
Kind of cast aside, frustrated,
sick, tired. And those are all emotions
because when I look at the video, I see myself.
- Sure.
- What are the exact emotions, the words that you
feel when you see those videos? Because I just
wonder—I agree with you that it is
impossible for a white person to fully
feel that; it will never be possible.
- Yeah.
- But so is it
sadness?
Is it guilt?
Is it, like, what are
the things that you see?
Cuz I wanna understand that as well.
- It's a great question.
I actually have a follow-up question
to you about what you just described.
So, so first of all, for
me, sadness, for sure.
Um,
guilt, for sure.
I don't wann call it white guilt,
but I will say it's guilt, and I'll
tell you why. Because I feel like
if, if I'm in a society where that is
allowed to happen in broad daylight,
where there's a modern-day lynching in
broad daylight in what is supposed
to be a progressive city in this
country, then I'm not doing enough.
That's where the guilt for me is.
I'm not doing enough.
I haven't done enough.
The people I know that have
an influence and have a voice,
they haven't done enough.
The, the overriding emotion for me was anger.
And so I wanted to ask you about this because
I think the anger for me and the anger for
a Black person is two different things.
- Yeah, no, I think it's such a deep-rooted
anger for Black people because it's the
kind of anger that is always there because
it feels like nothing at all is changing.
Um,
and realizing at some points that
you feel like you aren't in control
of your life. More importantly,
you're not gonna be in control of
your death and what the consequences
of that death probably won't be.
And I always think of, there's
this book and it's called On Earth
We're Briefly Gorgeous.
And the author in it, he talks about
hummingbirds, and he says looking
at a hummingbird moving so quickly
but staying in the same place.
I think that's what Black people feel
like, like a bunch of hummingbirds that
are having to do so much, but they're
not moving, and they're screaming
so loud, but no one is listening.
I mean, I have been angry
to the point that has driven
me to, like, hate. I don’t mean—
- Yes.
- Obviously
I don't mean hate all white people.
- OK.
- But I mean I hate
the person I see in that video.
- Sure.
- Think something bad should happen
to that person in that video
for hurting this person who didn't deserve it.
- Yes.
- So, like, there has to be a word that
is deeper than anger, you know?
- Right.
- And I think it's also scary sometimes
cuz I know that a lot of Black
people also feel incredibly numb to this.
Like, I have watched so many people that
could have been my friend die on my phone.
Like, normal-day scrolling, and then
they're shot and they're dead and
they're not ever gonna come back.
- Yeah.
- And it could have really been anybody.
It could have been any of us. This not
being able to do the simplest things.
So yeah, it's anger, but, like,
it's fear too, because the world,
because America has created this
system where this white person is
going to be more powerful than me.
And that's fear.
- Yeah.
- So I feel scared when I watch
the videos, and I feel very
angry when I watch the videos.
- So you mentioned the word, like, numb.
- Mhmm.
- And so I think what is really sad to
me is the notion that a Black person
can be so angry at that video
while simultaneously feeling
such a sense of despair, numbness,
coldheartedness, because as you just
described, they feel like a hummingbird
moving a million miles an hour in place.
And that is, that's sad.
That's really sad to me.
That's hard for me to
sort of reconcile.
It really is.
- Yeah, no, I think absolutely.
And it's, it's hard to live that way.
- Because there needs to be a, there needs to be—
you would hope in a progressive society,
you would hope that there could be a
way to use that anger in a positive way.
- Yeah, for sure.
- So it's like I'm angry.
That emotion when it subsides, if
it turns into a sense of despair,
a sense of numbness, a sense of
coldheartedness, then where have we gotten?
We've gotten to the same place that we just were.
- Agreed. Now,
and I think—so I saw this tweet, and it
was from a man named Dwayne Reed, and he
said, “White supremacy won't die until
white people see it as a white issue they
need to solve rather than a Black issue
they need to empathize with.”
- No doubt.
- And I do think a lot of white people are
feeling like, Well, I feel sad for you.
I'm empathizing.
I'm seeing you.
And, like, that's the role that I play,
when really the role that white people
play is dismantling the entire thing.
- Totally agree.
- And everybody has to feel that way for
there to be, like, any movement at all.
You know, the talking about it
isn't the work.
You know, actively seeing it in
your life and fixing it is the work.
- Right.
- And I also don't think
listening is the work.
I think it's important to
listen, but it isn't enough to
be like, “I wanna hear you.”
It's like, figure out the things that
you can do independently, the things
that you can do with your family
when you go home to try to change this
trend that has been here forever.
So I think, yeah, people's roles
are very different, and the burden
isn't on the oppressed. It's on
the oppressor. And you just, that's—
I think it's very important to
always make that distinction.
But I do know, obviously, this is a
super nuanced and complex conversation.
We talk about family.
How do you, or have you, or are you going
to speak to your kids about race?
- It's a great question.
So I just wanna go back to what you said just a second ago.
- Yeah.
- So, so first of all, you are
absolutely correct in that the system
was created by white people, and
it's going to have to be white
people that dismantle the system.
I agree with you.
I think when you mentioned, like,
listening is not the action, I would
just say to white people specifically,
it's part of the action, because if
you don't know what the conversation
is about, then you can't help. And
you've seen again and again, where
there's been some well-intentioned,
well-meaning white people who genuinely
I think are good people who wanna
help, but they've been a little tone-deaf
because they're not listening
to what the conversation is about.
And then the second part of
listening to me is acknowledgement.
So it's, it's listening
and then acknowledging.
And then we can start taking
action cuz we need to know—
“we” meaning “white people”—
we need to know exactly what
we're trying to solve here.
Cuz not all of us created the system,
and I'm not saying I'm not to blame.
What I'm saying is I'm not the, I
didn't vote for all the policy people.
You know, the systemic
racism that has been around
since slavery ended, obviously it's
slavery for 250 years, was even worse
than systemic racism, but—
- For sure. Yeah. It's not that white people are the problem.
It's that racism is.
- No, no, no. 100 percent.
- Yeah.
And I'm not saying you're saying it. I agree.
Like, it's not white people that
are the issue. Racism is the issue.
And the only
thing I'd say I have a
problem with listening—
I agree listening absolutely is a part of it—
- Yeah, sure.
But I think sometimes people equate listening
and hearing. It isn't enough to sit down
and just, like, listen to the Black person.
It's then translating that
into your everyday life.
So it's like, what actionable item are
you gonna take from the listening?
Is why I'm like it doesn't
just stop with listening.
Listening,
listening is important because
listening is step one, and then, you
know, step two and step three
and step four is where I think that
change comes, but you're absolutely right.
You have to listen to
figure out what's next.
- Yeah.
- But a lot of attention has to be put on, put on what's next.
- For sure.
So the family question that you just asked.
So, I already have—and not just
in the last three weeks—I've already
had these conversations with my kids.
We already talk about these things.
You know, especially with
the older one who is
fairly precocious and sort of gets
things and has always had sort of a good
understanding and is very observational.
Um,
you know, even with, you know—
it was a, it was a hard day
the day after the George Floyd
video came out cuz as parents,
you don't want your kids to see that.
Well, my son, my oldest—he's
getting ready to turn six—he
saw it.
- Wow.
Almost six.
And he saw it.
- Yeah.
And we watched, we let them
watch cartoons in the morning.
They watched a cartoon show
while they had breakfast.
And then at like 7:30, 8:00,
we put on The Today Show.
And so the video was on, it was
just on. And he's in the room still.
So he says, um, he said, “Mom,
I don't understand why that
police officer killed that man.
Why did he kill that man?
Police officers are good.
You know, police officers are good.”
That's, that's his worldview based
on whatever television—I mean,
I don't talk to him about police
officers—whatever television
he watches, whatever it is,
that's his worldview. Police officers are good.
Good guys.
There's good guys and
bad guys in everything
he watches.
Good guys.
Bad guys.
So having to explain to him
that not all police officers are
good, that police officers are
inherently meant to protect people and
inherently meant to serve people, but
that isn't always the case.
And to try to explain
that to a six-year-old is not
the easiest thing in the world.
Um,
you know, I'm just gonna be candid
with you about the idea of
teaching your kids about race.
So racism is in itself is
a learned behavior, right?
So I think a lot of people
say, like, “I'm colorblind.”
It's not an actual thing.
Like, we're human beings.
We, we make distinctions
and create categories.
It's from an evolutionary
standpoint. We've always done this.
This is not, like, a new thing.
So the conversation that I
have is, is—you know, I'll be very
frank with you—to a five-year-old,
here's what I tell my five-year-old:
“You treat everyone the same, no matter
what they look like, no matter what
they talk like, no matter how they
move, and no matter how they treat
you. You treat everybody the same.”
And, you know, we had a chance during
the first few weeks of quarantine
when they were still in school,
we were homeschooling every day.
So we would do a word of the week.
Um,
and the first, the first word
that we learned was respect.
And we went through every day, we
went through the different meanings
of what it meant to respect, you know,
and in a very small way, you
respect your parents, you respect your
family members, you respect your brother,
maybe treat your brother with respect.
How does that look,
right?
Then it was, how do you treat
other people with respect?
Obviously, there's only so much you
can teach your five- and three-year-olds.
- For sure.
- But these are things we're already doing.
- Mhmm.
- You know, I'm a Christian.
I subscribe to this guy Richard Rohr.
He's an incredible, incredible
thinker, incredible philosopher.
He's a Franciscan priest.
He works at this, at this
center out in New Mexico.
And his worldview is the
same worldview that I have.
And it's the same worldview that Jesus had.
And it's the same worldview that I want
my kids to have, which is basically,
you love everybody and you love God,
and everything else stems from that.
That's a very simplified version.
And obviously the world is way
more complicated than that.
But if that's your building
block and that's your foundation,
then it's really hard,
I think, to allow sort of those,
that evilness to creep in.
- Mhmm. For sure.
And you're right.
You know, I, I can't imagine how
you would frame that to somebody
that is five, you know?
- There's only so much developmentally a kid—
- For sure. But
obviously, I think, I think reflected
in your life, as you got older, you
were taught that in order to teach
someone about respect, you also have
to teach them about Black and white
and how those things are related.
- Yes. For sure. For sure.
- So how did your parents
do that to you or teach that to you?
Or how did you learn yourself
if it wasn't from your parents?
- No, it was from my parents.
Look, we, we grew up in, I would
consider where we grew up the South.
You know, if, if you live in
Virginia and you live in the D.C.
area, you're not from the South,
OK?
I'm not from the Deep South, but I
am from the South. Southern Virginia—
- No, for sure.
- Tennessee, like, it's the South.
And obviously some of these, um,
these thought processes
are embedded in the culture.
You know, we used to go down to
North Carolina for AAU tournaments, or
when I would drive down from Roanoke to
Duke, you had to pass through this
town in Franklin County, which
is the county directly south of Roanoke.
There's this little town
called Boones Mill.
It was known for two things.
It was a speed trap.
And number two, on the side of the
road, there were all these, um, like,
antique, you know, knickknack goods
stores with Confederate flags everywhere.
So you were reminded of that evilness,
again, evilness, you're reminded of that
every time you drove through the town.
So even though we were from the South,
my parents, you know, they grew up
in the North—one in Ohio,
one in Connecticut—met at college,
um,
so they had a different worldview than
a lot of people where I was raised.
And so, you know, again, we were, we were
just taught to love all people, to,
you know, treat people with respect.
I've had these conversations with—
my best friend in the world is
a mix of like four different races,
OK?
So we had these conversations all
the time, and I told him the other
day, I'm like, “You know, growing
up in my household, like, you didn't
make jokes about race or religion.
You didn't make jokes about gay people.
My parents did not raise us that
way.” As an adult, all
those things are so inappropriate.
They've always been inappropriate to me.
They're so inappropriate to me.
Going back to my kids,
like, my kids will never
hear me say those things.
Now,
I'm not doing this to toot my own horn.
What I'm saying is in some households,
that is loud, and that permeates
into a mindset of race, right?
These people above these people,
gays are here, straight are here,
trans are here, whatever it may be.
- It creates a status.
- Yes, exactly.
And that, my parents
didn't raise me that way,
didn't raise me that way at all.
And frankly, like, they allowed me,
you know, to go play with the city team.
They allowed me in high school to drive
four-and-a-half hours across
the state to play with Boo Williams
and give me those opportunities.
There was never any hesitation there.
It was just, you know, you
wanna be around the best people.
That's what it came down to.
- So how do you define racism?
Because, and I've talked about
this a couple of times on the series,
some people think racism means pointing to
the Black person, saying, “I don't like you
cuz you're Black.”
- Mmm, yeah.
- That's one very specific type of racism.
And I think one could argue, that's
probably the least threatening type
of racism. It’s the racism that manifests
itself in the things that we don't see,
in the systems that we live in every day,
including the police, that are the worst.
So what is racism
to you?
And also, how have you seen maybe white
people you know, white people around
you, exhibit these racist behaviors?
- I think racism, it's a, it's
a hard question to answer without
a dictionary in front of you,
first of all.
- Yeah.
- No, but racism to me is
just believing that because of
your skin color, you are superior
to a person of a different skin color.
I think that's a very broad
stroke there, but,
you know, it encapsulates a bunch of
different feelings, a bunch of
different real world sort of things.
The other thing I would say, because
my background in cultural anthropology—
so in cultural anthropology,
there's this, there's this notion of
the other, and the other can be
a bunch of different things, but in
general in culture, the other is
essentially something
that you see as a threat.
And I think, you know, it goes back
to something I read the other day
with Richard Rohr, where he was
talking about the ego lies to us.
And they think that if someone,
if someone, this group of people
that they want something that
I have. They want equal rights.
They want equal protection.
They want equal opportunity.
Well, somehow that's gonna take away
from my rights and my opportunity
when that's just not really how it works.
The pie is big enough for all of us.
- Sure.
- So I think, I think going along with that
sort of thinking of superiority, there's
also an underlying perception of threat.
- Yeah.
And I think what you're saying is true.
I also think the truth of the matter is
one of the reasons racism still exists
is because white people do recognize
that they have benefited from that system.
So it's almost, I don't wanna use the
word beneficial for racism to exist for
white people, but it has been beneficial
for racism to exist because when you
put it down to its base level, right,
if there have been so many movements,
so many people fighting for equal rights
for so many years, yet it still exists,
it's because people feel as though
it's necessary for things to continue
to operate in the way that they do.
- I totally agree with that.
I think, I think the group in power
will always want to hold on to
that power.
- Mhmm.
- And sometimes that can be done in a very subtle way.
And sometimes that can be
done in a very explicit way.
Um,
so if you, you know, if you go back to,
you know, the war on crime, the war
on drugs, you go back to Bill
Clinton's crime bill in the ‘90s.
Like, these were all at the time—
now we kind of, at least for me, I
didn't perceive that as a 10-year-old
when Clinton signed that bill in 1994—
but at the time I thought he was like,
Oh, let's put the bad guys in jail,
right?
At the time, you
know, it was, it was maybe
not as explicit as it seems
now, and now it seems pretty
explicit, that it was a war on Black people.
- Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely agree.
- Taylor, Taylor, can
I ask you a question?
- Absolutely.
- Not, not a book definition, but
to you, what is, what is your,
what is your definition of racism?
- I think racism
is a structure,
a structure that
puts one person in power and one
person not in power. For me
that's—racism is when a white person
is in power and uses that power
to keep Black people not in power.
And I don't mean power in the huge term.
I mean agency. I mean the power
to just be you, the power to do
things you want to do every day.
So,
yeah,
so any time that a white person's power
threatens my existence, that's racism.
- Yeah.
- The same way,
I think any time a person, a
white person's white privilege
threatens my agency, that's racism.
Um, whether they are actively
participating in that racism or not, it's
that racism is so ingrained in everything
that I'm experiencing the racism,
even though you might not feel like
you're doing something that is racist.
Because the thing we're living
in creates that environment.
Does that make sense? - For sure.
Um, you mentioned, you mentioned agency
by the way, and I've, I've said this, I've
said this publicly before, but for some
reason, every time I say it, like, people
freak out. But like, so Kevin Durant in
2016, when he joined the Warriors, LeBron,
when he makes The Decision, there's
always the group of sports fans who
want to make the argument,
“Oh, he took the easy way out.
You know, he went and joined Dwyane
Wade and Chris Bosh in Miami.
He went and joined a team
that had just beat him in
the playoffs.” Like,
I'm not gonna use any explicitives,
you know, but you know what I'm saying?
There's that, there's that notion.
But I think an underlying—I
really believe this—an underlying
reason for the, sort of the
reaction to Kevin and LeBron making
those decisions is because people
were uncomfortable with powerful Black
men making a decision for themselves.
I really believe that.
- Yeah.
- And that goes back to
systemic racism in our society.
Like, again, it goes back
to what I was saying too.
It's about the threat, the
perception of a threat.
Well, the perception: Wait a minute,
this guy, he's, he's bucking the system.
- How dare he?
- How dare he? He's bucking the system.
- And I think—oh, I'm sorry.
Didn't mean to cut you off.
- No, I was just going to say, you know,
when Kevin did that in 2016—this
is when my podcast was on Yahoo—
I did a whole episode on this. I did a whole episode.
I mean, I just fucking loved the decision.
I loved what he did. Now,
I was on the Clippers at the time, and
we were trying to beat the Warriors,
so I was like, “Yeah, well
we're, we're in trouble.”
But, uh, but I, you know, I loved,
I loved him taking ownership of
that agency and just saying, “No,
I'm going to do what I want to do.”
- Yeah.
And I think that really speaks in a lot of
ways to sports in general, which is, it's
a lot of Black people making decisions
and a lot of white people telling them why
that decision maybe was right or wrong.
- Interesting. I’ve never heard it framed that way, but yeah.
- Which is a lot of what it is.
I, you know—one thing that I think
is great about both of those guys,
with LeBron and Kevin, is that they
have done obviously a lot of things
on the basketball court, but they
have also done so many things for
Black people, for people in general
in business, et cetera, et cetera.
Two things with that, though
is, I hate that Black people
feel as though they have to be
this excellent being in
order to be considered good,
right?
And I think that a lot of Black, I
think a lot of Black people experience
that—the need to be the best in order
to justify your existence, because white
people simply do not have to do that.
I think it's great that
Black people do it.
I just hate that
we feel like we have to. That's A.
B, there's always this perceived
idea that, you know, if you're
rich, you can beat racism.
If you're educated, you can beat racism.
If you look this way, you can beat
racism, that all of these things
will be able to be your armor to
stop white people from not liking
you simply because you're Black.
I would argue—
and this is the case probably for LeBron
and Kevin—that being all three of those
things in a lot of ways makes you a target
because it goes back to what you talk
about with the threat or feeling like, "Why
does this person have this when I don't?"
So while sometimes these conversations
happen, and maybe famous or
more wealthy Black people are
framed like they have it easy,
it's important to understand how racism
still exists for the Kevin Durants and
the LeBron James and every Black person
who was doing something in the public
eye, because it's absolutely still there.
It's just showing itself
in, in a different way.
You know, it's showing itself in
the people that want to burn Kevin
Durant's jersey because he made a
decision to make his life better.
- It's uh, it's the, the, the first thing
you said, it's pretty profound actually.
Um,
about, about goodness and measuring
up to white people's goodness as if
that somehow absolves you from racism.
Um, I mean, and that's the fact that
maybe some people think like that and
some people feel the need to do that,
it's, it's incredibly sad, but it just, I
think it speaks volumes—because it's true,
what you say— it speaks volumes to
how shitty our society is in that regard.
- Yeah. And it speaks to—
- Cuz it's not, it's not authentic at all.
- Yeah.
- It's not authentic
- And that the whole system shouldn't be in place
- It feels like your value
isn't in you being a human.
Your value is in, like, the
things that you can do.
And I just don't think,
I think that's a very
toxic way that sometimes that people
have to live, that you have to
have things that like, like I said,
justify the space that you take up.
And it's sad, and it's
more than it being sad,
it's exhausting, you know. Do I, I
always got to be the best, you know,
I always got to be way better than
everybody else in this room, just for
you to think that I belong in the room.
- Right.
- But yeah, it is a part of it.
Um, I want to end with this,
which is the same question that
I ask everybody at the end, which
is that words mean different
things to different people.
How do you define America?
- So I'm reading this book right now.
I didn’t know that you were gonna ask me this question.
- It’s right there!
- So it's written by Colin Woodard.
So it was written a few years ago.
This is actually a follow-up to a book
that was written back in the ‘70s.
I think it was called The
Nine American Nations. Colin
calls his book, American Nations.
And he argues that basically
there's 11 nations in our country.
So with that as sort of the
foundation, I think the easiest
way to define America is messy.
The reason it's messy, it's for
a lot of reasons, but there's
so many competing ideologies,
there's so many competing agendas in
America because of its history of slavery
and systemic oppression, especially
of obviously of Black people,
we can never really, we can never
really be clean. Even if we ever
reconciled that, we could never be clean.
America's always going to be messy.
Now the Constitution, I think,
has done a good enough job
to keep our society running.
Um, but when you have someone like
Trump in office who has empowered, um,
even further empowered
some racist ideology, um,
and white nationalism, it
makes things really messy.
And at times it feels untenable.
At times this society, this
country feels untenable.
Like we're on the brink. I assume—
I’m, I’m
talking about everybody, white
people, Black people, everybody—
I assume that we've all
felt this way before.
And whether that was, you know,
in the late ‘60s, World War II,
um,
obviously during the Civil War, but
if you look, it's funny, cuz if you
look at all the times that our society
and our country has really been at odds,
it's been centered around race.
So that's, that's my
definition. Messy, messy.
America's messy.
- That was thoughtful.
- And a lot of, and a lot of it is, is race.
- And yeah, you said something true.
You're like, you know, so
many things have happened.
I don't know if it would ever be completely
not messy, but I hope that everybody
can do their part to just clean it
up as much as, as much as possible.
For sure.
- Yeah.
Look, we need to do a better job.
We, as in sort of our generation,
we need to do a better job
of participating in all elections.
And I just want to give you some
credit because you recently voted, uh,
in Georgia in the primaries, right?
- Yes! Vote! Yes! It’s so important!
- I just want to just say
thanks for doing that.
- Thank you.
- Um, you know, I've, I've, I've voted in
the national election since 2004 and in
some state elections, but I’ve, I've never
been consistent with local elections.
And so this is, going forward,
this is sort of one of my, you know, touch
points for me about how can I be better,
right?
And so that's one of them.
Um,
and the other thing is, you
know, what's really interesting
that’s happening right now.
Like, we have so far to go,
Taylor, you and I could agree.
We have so far to go. But for
me, I'm trying to be an optimist,
and I'm trying to be an optimist.
It's been three weeks or so,
it’s been three weeks or so since, since
George Floyd was murdered, and
we're already seeing action,
we're already seeing some action.
You know, we've seen local police
departments already and local
governments already enact some of these
changes that we've been asking for
with, with no chokeholds, [New York City Mayor Bill] De Blasio
comes out and he says, we're going
to, we're going to reallocate some
funds from the NYPD to other areas.
Um,
so things are happening.
I think people are finally
sort of listening. For anybody
who's listening to this,
we have to continue.
We have to keep going, we have to continue.
- Yes. No, I agree.
- Like, this is not going to
be something that just lasts
during the summer or something
that just lasts during COVID.
Um,
you know, this is something
that's gotta, it's gotta be,
you know, years, possibly generations to make it.
We have got to do this.
I want to end with one thing, and
sorry to be long-winded.
The first few days after, um,
after, uh, George Floyd was murdered,
you know, I, again, I, I referred it,
referred to it earlier as a modern-day
lynching in broad daylight with
the guy knowing a camera was on him.
So two of my heroes growing up, you know,
when I was at Duke were, were
Tommie Smith and John Carlos, and I wrote
two, like, 30-page papers on these guys.
I had the opportunity last, last fall, the
Pelicans brought in Tommie and Edwin Moses,
who was another, uh, you know, hero,
amazing athlete, political activist,
that came in and talked.
- Wait. Just so everyone knows watching if they don't know, I'm
sure everyone's seen the iconic photo of
two Black men fists up at the Olympics.
That is who JJ is referring to.
- Tommie wins the gold medal.
He sets the world record in the 200-meter
Olympic Games in Mexico City in 1968.
John Carlos wins the bronze.
And they had agreed upon
doing a couple things.
So, you know, they, they did
the Black Power fist up.
John actually forgot his gloves.
So Tommie gave him his left-handed glove.
- Yup. Oh, I read this story.
- So John put up his left hand.
So there was a couple of things that
they were protesting, but so Tom is
up there with no shoes on, and he's
protesting against, uh, the poverty
in the, in the Black community.
John, John Carlos has a, uh, has this, like,
necklace or chain around his neck.
And he was, he was protesting the
lynching of Black people. That was in 1968.
It was 52 years ago.
- Not that long.
- Not that long. Right.
- Not that long ago. Like,
that was yesterday.
- 52 years later, we all get to witness,
we all had to witness,
I should say, we all witnessed a Black
man being lynched for the same thing
that he was protesting 52 years ago.
So we can make an argument, right?
Civil Rights Act gets
signed into law in 1964.
We can make an argument that things
are marginally, marginally better,
better for Black people in America.
But,
I'm 35.
If I say in 52 years that things
are marginally better than they
were 52 years ago for Black people
in America, then I failed. And we’ve all failed.
- Absolutely.
- We’ve all failed.
And I, and I would encourage, there's a
lot of really great articles about the
white allyship moment between all three.
Like there's very longform articles
about that, that I encourage
everyone to read. And you're right.
It's just crazy that,
yes, that was so long ago, but it's
even wild that we were dealing with.
Like, my mom was born at that time,
you know, so, but you're right.
I think it's gonna take an
accumulation of moments like that
and people wanting to work together
in that way for anything to be better.
You were,
you were so thoughtful and you
offered so many great insights.
So I'm, I'm so thankful to you
for doing this and coming on.
- Well, thanks for asking me to do this.
I appreciate it. Thank you.
- Yeah. Absolutely.